Get in a horse dance like you're going
to do showman suburi.
He's wherever is fine. I'm just
watching. You're okay. Go ahead and get
in it. But he Sean doesn't want you
hitting that. But we weren't going to do
shaman subi like you're going to do
shammani. Okay.
All right. Hold the book in like you
were going to start showman subi.
Okay. Where does the left hand go?
The left hand one fist width away from
your body. Where on the bulk end?
Am I at the back end?
>> No. Your pinky goes on the end.
Your pinky is on the end. You see that?
Pinkie is on the end. Okay. And then
Virginia's point is is one fist away
from my body.
Got it. So this is too far out.
One fist away from my body. Okay.
All right. Let us
note where this hand is away from your
body. Everyone got that? Okay.
Let's note where this hand is. Got that?
It's two different distances here.
And let's do this one up here because
this is where a lot of people do their
sub.
They're like here. Okay. So, we're we're
I don't know a handspan away. and you're
maybe three inches above your navl.
Okay.
If I am trying to use the hands to drop
the heaven aspect, the yong aspect,
where do we put them? Right around here.
Right around here.
You put them up here.
Got it.
You're usually bringing it up
usually this way. You don't want it to
go up at the bottom of the cut. You want
it to go down.
So,
this is where we're at down here. So, if
you're not, you're like, "That feels
weird." I know it feels weird, but go
like this.
Form your lang
and let the yang aspect drop.
And when you have la gong, you'll feel
that
whatever that is in my palms. Okay?
And if you're sensitive,
when you start to bring this up, you'll
feel more in your palms, but you you
should feel it coming up your body.
Do you understand? Okay. So when we're
up here and now I go down, you should
feel it more in your feet
on that kidney spot and you settle more.
Do do you understand? Okay. So on the
bottom of shenan I was supposed to be
cutting down then I should cut down.
That's where I cut down to. Okay. Make
sense? Okay. Now let's watch this. Uh,
go ahead and slowly lift the sword up
and then slowly lift the sword down.
Keep doing it.
Okay. Again, finish.
Good. Now, in Virginia, you're doing
this, too.
What do you notice
about his shoulders?
You can come look.
Well, what do you what's touching the
bulkhead?
>> And what's not touching the bulkhead?
His left shoulder.
Come back on the quad now.
And the quad goes forward. Do you
understand? Okay. You're doing that too,
Virginia. Okay.
So
what I'm going to tell you is that is
happening from the tension that you have
in the right arm. So start out what you
think is even. Okay? And then just start
leaving the left arm tense, tense the
right arm. This is a discovery learning
exercise. And when I say tense, I mean
squeeze the hell out of that right arm.
And then notice how oh my shoulder is
forward and the claw came slightly
forward. Okay, do you guys see that? All
right. What people do, this is one
reason why you see people bring back
here.
Do do you get the come back here?
Because the the weapon is fighting the
tension and they loosen the tension and
the hand will come back. Okay,
but here's this. Watch this.
If my hand is coming up the middle, I
bring it up the middle and I don't have
tension.
Do you see? And I bring the other hand
up the middle.
It's not making me turn.
Just bring the hand up the middle. Down
the middle. This was the exercise.
Okay,
if you pay attention
when you
add that tension
and start to make this thing
be more of a form as opposed to follow
the tension in your body,
you do weird things
like this. You see that? And now there's
the tension in my arm. And now I have to
stop. And now the sword is up here. But
if I just let it drop, and if you pay
attention, yes, both hands are on the
center line, but they're not in the same
point on the arc of the arm through
space at the same time. Do you get that?
So if this hand did not bring a shoulder
forward or back, then even though this
hand is further on the sword, it should
not bring a shoulder forward or back
because it is at a different place on
the ark. Do do you guys get what I'm
saying? Okay. So, usually we can't feel
the arc when we're doing something like
just hitting.
So, forget sword cutting. And I'm going
to have you bring your hand in even a
little, not side by side, but just a
little to get you there. Okay? And just
realize that the hands are not doing the
same thing at the same time.
Do you understand? Okay. See if you can
feel that. And I'll bring your mind to
the wrist flexion. Okay. So, for
example, as I start, if I kept my wrists
the same as they are right now, and I
move my arms up, I keep that wrist
flexion,
I'm never going to get to the up part.
Do you understand? So, the elbow is
flexing, the wrist is flexing. Do do you
understand? Okay.
There's a time in the arc where that
happens without tension.
That's what I don't know yet because I'm
trying to move the sword as opposed to
let the sword move me. Okay. So, what I
want you to do in this exercise is we're
going to come back a little bit to get a
fighting chance. And you'll see that the
wrists are not exactly in the same
flexion
at the same time. Do do you get that?
But I don't want to do this either.
Okay.
The elbows too are not in the same
articulation angle as I'm going through.
And if I just measure for tension in my
body, you'll find it.
Okay. Try it.
Bring the left hand back where it goes.
Don't let tension come in your body.
Now bring some awareness to your
shoulders and your claw because you
might just be doing it out of habit. So
keep your shoulders and claws square as
you monitor for tension through your
arms, wrist, fingers.
Keep your shoulders square and your claw
square.
Okay. So, now we'll watch. That was
going up. Now we watch for going down.
Okay. So, if I come down and you watch
watch my elbows, this is you. You get
this problem. You know what I'm talking
about. I mentioned that you have you
have uh greater wrist flexion and you're
trying to do it at the same time. Your
elbows are doing it at the same time,
too. The elbows can't be at the same
time because the hands aren't in the
same position of the arc at the same
time. They can no more be in the same
time than the wrist can be. And that is
important coming down. So, if I try to
come down with my elbows at the exact
same articulation, the sword will never
get out and do the cut. Do do you
understand that? So they don't go at the
same time. So as I come out, you can see
they don't have the exact same angle of
articulation.
Do you see that? They don't. Okay? And
if you just follow
just like yinyang, one hand's doing one
thing, the other hand's never doing the
same exact thing at the same time. Okay?
Right? So, one hand is doing an inward
spiral, other hand is doing an outward
spiral. Okay? One hand is yong, one hand
is yin. Same thing here. Don't make them
go at the same time. What's what's my
clue I want you to do is I want you to
feel no tension in the arm and the grip.
And the sword is moving your
shoulders, arms, all that through space.
Okay? So, let's bring that. Go.
Don't pull both elbows down
at the same rate.
Don't bring them up at the same rate.
Send that sword out. You have wrist
angles that got to be the same.
So very very common. A lot of people do
this is they're trying to stack the
weapon. Do you see how it's stacked? You
see that? And then they come down and
they stack the weapon again.
Understand?
>> Okay.
So here I am stacked and you can see
that my wrists are in the same angle.
They should not be in the same angle.
Got it? They're in different places on
that arc. There should not be a time
when they're over each other like that.
In which case, the sword should never
end up here. Neither going forward. No,
no, no, no. Okay. They're doing
different things at They're doing the
same thing, but at different rates. At
different rates. At different rates.
They're following each other. Same
thing. Following each other. Okay, try
it again.
And they follow each other all the way
down to the bottom.
Don't stack it.
All the way down. Let the left hand
drop. Let the left hand drop.
All right. Marshially there's two
reasons for this. So, if we were in Sean
and if I stack the sword going up,
you're going to see that the sword is no
longer threatening him. It's not
threatening him. The sword is
threatening threatening threatening
threatening. So, the threat the threat
threshold stays longer than if I stack
the sword, it goes away earlier. On the
cut, you're going to have a chop.
You're gonna chop and a wrist flick as
opposed to just letting the weapon do
its thing. Do you understand? Okay. Um,
so again, a little bit more. Do not
stack the sword going up. Do not stack
the sword going down. Go.